use the quadratic formula to solve the
equation zero is equal to negative seven
q squared plus two q
plus
nine
now the quadratic formula it applies to
any quadratic equation of the form we
can put the zero on the left-hand side
zero is equal to a
x squared plus b x
plus c and we we generally deal with x's
in this problem we're dealing with q's
but the quadratic formula says look if
you have a quadratic equation of this
form that the solutions the solutions of
this equation are going to be x is going
to be equal to negative b
negative b plus or minus the square root
of b squared minus 4ac
all of that over
2a
and this is actually two solutions here
because there's one solution where you
take the positive square root and
there's another solution where you take
the negative solution the negative root
so it gives you both roots of this so if
we look at the the quadratic equation
that we need to solve here we can just
pattern match we're dealing with q's not
x's but it's the same general idea it
could be x's if you like and if we look
at it
negative 7 corresponds to a
that is our a it's the coefficient on
the second degree term
2 corresponds to b
it is the coefficient on the first
degree term
and then 9 corresponds to c it's the
constant it's the constant so let's just
apply the quadratic formula the
quadratic formula will tell us that the
solutions the q's that satisfy this
equation q
will be equal to negative b
b is 2
plus or minus
the square root
of b squared of b squared of 2 squared
2 squared minus
minus 4
times a times negative 7 times negative
times
c
times c which is 9 times 9 and all of
that over 2a
all of that over
all of that over 2 times a which is once
again negative 7
which is negative 7.
and then we just have to evaluate this
so this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to negative 2
negative 2 plus or minus the square root
of
see 2 squared is 4
and then if we just take this part right
here if we take the negative 4 times
negative 7 times 9 this negative and
that negative is going to cancel out so
it's just going to become a positive
number and 4 times 7 times 9. four times
see four times nine is 36 36 times seven
let's do it up here
36 times 7 7 times 6 is 42
7 times 3 or 3 times 7 is 21 plus 4 is
252 so this becomes 4 plus 252 remember
this is a you have a negative 7 and you
have a minus out front those cancel out
that's why we have a positive 252 for
that part right there
and then our denominator
our denominator 2 times negative 7 is
negative 14.
now what does this equal
what does this equal
well we have
this is equal to negative 2 plus or
minus the square root of what's 4 plus
252 it's just 256.
all of that over negative 14. and what's
that's
what's the square root of 256
it's 16 you can try it out for yourself
this is 16 times 16. so the square root
of 256
is 16. so we can rewrite this whole
thing as being equal to
negative 2
plus
this plus 16
over negative 14 or
negative 2 minus right this is plus 16
over negative 14 or minus 16
or minus 16 over negative 14 right if
you think of it plus or minus that plus
is that plus right there and if you have
if you have that minus
that minus is that minus right there now
we just have to evaluate these two
numbers
just have to evaluate them negative 2
plus 16
is 14 divided by negative 14 is negative
1. so q could be equal to negative 1
or
negative 2 minus 16 is negative 18
divided by negative 14
is equal to 18 over 14 the negatives
cancel out which is equal to 9 over 7.
so q could be equal negative 1 or it
could be equal to 9 over 7. and you
could try these out substitute these
cubes back into this original equation
and verify for yourself that they
satisfy it we could even do it with the
first one
so if you take q is equal to negative 1
negative 7 times negative 1 squared
negative 1 squared is just 1. so this it
would be negative 7 times 1 right that's
negative 1 squared
negative 1 times 2 is minus 2
plus 9. so it's my it's negative 7 minus
2 which is negative 9 plus 9 does indeed
equal 0. so this checks out and i'll
leave it up to you to to verify that 9
over 7 also works out